okay so Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
feels like a home run for the MCU after
a lot of underwhelming projects recently
it did feel like the franchise had
somewhat lost its appeal instead of the
heart and creativity that had once made
the studio special we weren't used to
what felt like products just coming off
an assembly line whether it was in the
cinemas or on the Disney Plus shows it
just seemed like Marvel were bombarding
us with a lot of mediocrity where the
folks had been solely on making as much
money as possible we've had Ant-Man in
the WASP Quantum media Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of mid-ness and many more
there's lots of talk about superhero
fatigue at the moment and with Marvel
being the biggest producer of content in
the genre it felt like this once
gigantic Juggernaut had somewhat lost
its way it's the same thing that's
unfortunately happened with Star Wars
razzy's projects once felt like major
events he could miss out on people are
happy to skip them now because they
don't really feel like they matter the
the mid the middle Orion
sake now you know I love comic books but
it had got to the point where even I
thought things were getting
oversaturated and there weren't any
stories that felt like they innovated
and raised the bar I was actually
talking with a Canadian lad about this
last week and we got into how many
projects there were coming out and how
it's also really cringy when YouTubers
named drop other YouTubers to make
themselves sound important but I was
saying that the current slate feels like
back in the day when you go into a comic
shop and pick up one of their
pre-packaged bundle of books where there
was about 10 put in a black bag and it
was labeled something like mystery mix
the price was pretty cheap so it seemed
like a good deal but upon opening it up
at home you'd see there were some good
ones but most of them were meh in the
end you'd read about three of them and
the other seven were ones that you
weren't really interested in so you just
never opened them up I kind of feel like
that's what the car instead of Affairs
is where we've been given a big bundle
of books but there's a lot we can't
actually be bothered to read and we're
just sitting around skimming through the
ones that might end up being interesting
everyone's getting a comic book movie a
show these days but the C and d-list
characters are no longer the Innovative
ones that they used to be Batman and
Superman always had a big audience so
they could afford to do things by the
numbers and it was normally the more
obscure characters that had to do things
differently in order to stand out
however I feel like the Batman and the
Joker are being far more creative
nowadays whereas the ones like Shazam
and Ant-Man are the franchises burning
it in by that I'm happy to say that
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 shows that
when you have someone putting their
heart and soul into something that it
can take things to the next level within
the movie there's one scene that I think
not only exemplifies why I fell in love
with the genre but it also thematically
brings together all the elements that
made the franchise so successful that is
of course the corridor scene towards the
end feels like James Gunn's going Super
Saiyan and this brings together
everything he's learned since that first
Guardians movie to make this moment his
Masterpiece now to give some context to
why it works so well we have to look at
what the Guardians have gone through
after an attack by Adam Warlock earlier
in the movie their faithful squirrel
Hedgehog hamster rocket was left at
death's door discovering a kill switch
within him that would activate if they
attempted to use a med pack they set out
to go and meet his maker this stuck them
to the high evolutionary who wiped out
an entire planet of his experiment
because he didn't think they lived up to
his standard the group had split up
beforehand in order to go meet him and
the planet's destruction pushed them
further apart by that just before this
scene they managed to finally reunite in
the hangar of the high evolutionary ship
quill said they had to go rescue mantis
Drax and nebula but they made a big
entrance by bursting through the walls
on the back of some obelisks now at this
point the group could easily go off and
fly back to Nowhere leaving The
evolutionary to his own ends after all
his experiments had been disrupted and
he'd even had his subjects turn against
him and try and form a coup whether it's
just one little thing the ship is full
of animals and children that the high
evolutionary could subject to more
experiments getting Flash backs of what
it was like under the knife Rocket
valiantly says that he's not running
anymore and the pair man up to save the
others this really exemplifies what
makes the Guardians the Guardians and
this group is very much a voice for the
Misfits and outcasts who are often
overlooked superhero movies are one
point fell into the cliche of centering
around saving the girl with Lois Lane
and so on always being the damsels in
distress that got in danger it's rare to
see the freaks giving a voice but the
Guardians are very much seen as their
Champions before the first film was
released no one thought the movie would
be successful because this was a team
made up of a raccoon and a talking tree
however Gunn has always been a voice for
obscuring overlooked characters which
the Guardians and the evolutionaries
victims exemplify you can argue all day
about animal testing for farming the
dairy industry and the cruelty within
them is often something we put to the
back of our minds when we're eating and
enjoying ourselves going off in a big
tangent there but I think gun purposely
put animals in kits in cages to maybe
try and act as metaphors for things in
our world as a way to kind of be a voice
for the voiceless it's there if you want
to see it and not if you don't but it
adds a nice layer of subtext to what the
Guardians are trying to accomplish here
and whether you think that's later at
the movie or not I think there's no
denying just how good this scene plays
out said to the Beastie Boys No Sleep
till Brooklyn this signature song
carries its own meaning that ties in
with the group itself the track is about
touring and in it the rappers talk about
how tiring it can be going on these
gigantic Journeys from City to City away
from home facing the monotony of just
playing the same songs over and over
again and they're just without a sense
of place where that lays throughout the
music is a sense of determination and
they say they won't rest until they
reach their home in Brooklyn now
metaphorically that's what the Guardians
are going through as well they've been
broken up broken apart and have been
through battle after battle but they
won't stop until they say the day and
then get home it works perfect in this
moment and it also showcases guns
signature style in full effect this is a
director who's built his name of making
moments almost like music videos and
he's an expert when he comes to
selecting a song to put into a scene
every guardian's film has had its own
soundtrack and we've gone from cassettes
all the way up to zude which Peter plays
at the start of the scene to kick things
off now as for the moment itself you
just have to Marvel at the technical
work behind it one shot takes a
ridiculously hard to put together but
Gunn has this hallway scene flowing
beautifully from one character to the
next shows all their strengths and
weaknesses and it really exemplifies how
good the group are we have Groot
stuffing a branch down a hell spawn and
then exploding it from the inside quell
throwing electrical charges on guards
and Drax pinning someone to the wall
with his knife we even get called backs
of the prior films with rockets standing
on Groot shoulder shooting and quills
charge being something that he's used in
other movies a favorite moment though by
far is watching nebula get punched in
the head to see it go over the back of
her body lots of her bones and parts are
broken during this moment and I love how
she pulls everything back together in
place and keeps firing the movie is of
course laced with a lot of body horror
but this is the moment that stands out
to me now we end the scene with Gamora
fighting off against one of the
evolutionary squid-headed hell spawn
she's a character who hasn't really felt
like she's part of the group and this is
due to all the stuff that happened with
the Multiverse earlier in the franchise
quill is tried his hardest to get her
back with him and I think that is during
this moment that she finally feels like
she's part of the team again ending on
her and having the team all standing
about panning is such an outstanding way
to close it out and the final show the
group altogether works so well to show
that they're once more united a while of
this scene is because of the
choreography on display the way the
camera does things like move through the
stomach of a creature the way that we
see the Guardians all working together
and the way that the music reminds us of
what's really going on in this moment
this is the team coming together for one
final time to show us why we fell in
love with them in the first place it's
got some great callbacks it's
beautifully executed it shows the entire
team both in front and behind the camera
at their best I don't know if this is
the best action scene in the MCU but I'm
hard-pressed to think of another one
that tops it in the end I can't wait to
re-watch this moment again and that to
me is why it's perfect now if you agree
or not I'd love to hear your thoughts on
it so make sure you drop them down in
the comments section below if you want
to support the channel we've just
launched a new James Gunn inspired
t-shirt I brought a shop Zero edition
says can't see us because because they
both go in invisible and and anyway the
shirts are super high quality and we've
worked with manufacturers directly to
make it so they sit and Contour to your
body to bring out the best in you it's a
joint venture between me Ryan at screen
crushing gregorial Rejects and it helps
to keep us all bringing you videos just
like this link to it is in the
description and thank you so much if you
decide to pick it up our Theory time
merch or something else for you or a
loved one now if you want something else
to watch then check oh Brighton of who
Adam Warlock is and also a video on why
fire level could end up becoming
extremely important please hit the
Thumbs Up Button if you enjoy the
breakdown and make sure you subscribe of
videos like this every day by the way
I've been Paul you've been the best and
thanks for stopping by the heavy
spoilers shot you take care of yourself
I'll see you next time peace